and I do hereby declare that Vernon
Coker is duly elected
[Applause]
you know can I can I start first of all
by thanking John Robinson is the
returning officer all of the staff here
we've counted the votes and from calton
forum here also the police and others
who've made this all happen can I also
thank my family Jackie my wife but also
all of my family who've been involved
for quite a few weeks a my agent Mark
Glover and all of the fantastic
volunteers all of the fantastic
volunteers that that we've had can I
also just say on a serious that we deny
all of us on a night where it's a
celebration of our democracy I think we
should also remember the victims and
their families of the two horrendous
terrorist attacks that there have been
during the campaign and I think the way
in which all of the parties and all of
the people of our democracy in our
country responded to that showed in the
face of that horror the very best of our
country and I think we should remember
that at this time as well the election
as far as I was concerned and as far as
my party was concerned was a view of
competing visions of the future of
Britain there are very serious
challenges facing our country you can
see across the country that people
believe that we need a different
approach that a hard break set which was
one is being pursued by the current
government and something needs to be
done about a break see that works in the
interests of everyone and seeks to work
with Europe and come to a deal with
Europe rather than threatening Europe to
try to come to that deal and I think one
of the ways in which came up time and
time again when we talk to people in
Gately was the way in which it was so
important
example to guarantee the rights of EU
nationals already living in this country
to be guaranteed the right of residence
here rather than threaten them in using
them as a bargaining chip I think also
people saw very clearly that there was a
sense in which people desperately want a
different type of society with fairness
and equality and the gap between rich
and poor is narrow but there's proper
investment for our schools and for our
hospitals opportunities for our young
people and I think again here engaging
as well as across the country people
feel that that is important and
something that they voted for and
something that they wish to see but
finally I want to say this it's been an
immense privilege for me to be the
Member of Parliament for gatling since
1997 and I want to thank the people of
gatling for relating me again in this
election here in 2017 it's a great honor
and it is a privilege and I know that
not everybody voted for me but I've
always tried and I reiterate this again
I will always try even if I don't always
succeed to do the very best to stand up
for the people of gatling to fight for
the for their interests to be their
champion here locally but also to fight
for them in Parliament as well and I
look forward to that over the period of
the next poll I'm delighted to have
being reelected and once again thank you
to the people of getting thanks very
much indeed
[Applause]